let's talk about GM and American
automobiles electric vehicles subsidies
the world economy geopolitics I don't
know where to start other than to say
that Donald Trump is now threatening to
punish American people who buy electric
cars which I suspect more and more
Americans will be doing every year from
here on out why would Donald Trump do
this he has come up with this as a way
to punish General Motors for
restructuring in the direction of
electric cars part of that restructuring
as I told you on Monday or Tuesday is
that General Motors and Ford are both
going to be laying off about 12 to 15
percent of their salaried workforce they
announced that earlier this week now
before I tell you what Trump is
threatening to do remember that Donald
Trump promised to bring manufacturing
jobs back to the United States he said
that auto industry jobs were coming back
all sorts of stuff that's demonstrably
not true that Trump has no idea about
and that simply is not going to happen
so as a baseline Donald Trump isn't
pleased because the real world facts
once again are contradicting the lies of
Donald Trump lies told during the
campaign lies told after he was
inaugurated President of the United
States so what does Trump say he
threatens to cut subsidies on electric
cars which help general motors sell
electric cars but importantly are
rebates for the buyer okay and we'll get
into that in a second Donald Trump
tweeting about this issue quote very
disappointed with General Motors and
their CEO Mary Barra for closing plants
in Ohio Michigan and Maryland nothing
being closed in Mexico and China the
u.s. saved General Motors and this is
the thanks we get we are now looking at
cutting all GM subsidies including for
electric cars
General Motors made a big China bet
years ago when they built plants there
and in Mexico don't think that bed is
going to pay off I am here to protect
America's workers to understand how
insane this is
consider all of the following okay
number one the United States is already
hilariously behind on electric vehicles
other than Tesla and it's not even clear
that Donald Trump likes Tesla number two
Donald Trump is one of the biggest
culprits of manufacturing his own
tchotchkes everywhere but the United
States in order to do it as cheaply as
possible so he's a hypocrite on this
issue number three it is true that
subsidies on electric cars helped
General Motors sell more of those cars
but the savings on those cars the
rebates the credits on those vehicles go
to the individuals who are buying the
cars so in reality you're hurting the
individual consumer when you if you
eliminate these subsidies number four
the subsidies aren't specific to general
motors electric car subsidies are
industry-wide okay they are federal tax
credits of seventy five hundred bucks
for American electric cars up to two
hundred thousand vehicles per
manufacturer so if Donald Trump gets rid
of these subsidies they aren't just
subsidies for general motors these are
subsidies for all manufacturers that I
guess he isn't trying to punish
potentially and number five these are
once again targeted threats to
individual companies from the President
of the United States for something that
in the end is partially his fault right
if you want to help manufacturing do
something to improve the business
environment that's the opposite of
putting tariffs on the raw materials
that automakers need so this entire
thing is a problem precipitated by
Donald Trump's terrible economic policy
his ideas are as misguided as they are
stupid and as destructive as they are
embarrassing but there is a contingent
of the electorate Pat that will see this
they'll see the tariffs and they'll see
Trump slamming GM and threatening with
the removal of electric car subsidies
and they'll say I like it he's being
tough he's getting serious on
manufacturing which completely ignores
the fact that what he's doing hurts
these companies yeah and Trump is acting
so offended by what GM has done here
maybe because he thought that by giving
them some big tax break that would mean
that GM would keep the American workers
employed no they're just gonna do
whatever maximizes their profits that's
what corporations do and there really
should be no surprise here no question
about it that's the thing there's some
of these stories it's like they're so
obvious in a sense and it's sort of a
weird place to be in because a lot of
our core audience understands this stuff
and the people that don't are often
willingly ignorant they're deliberately
ignoring the empirical realities of how
the world works and how basic economics
works and it's just not going to matter
in the end and that's why it's
ultimately it's all I mean what what
this all comes down to is just voter
turnout right do enough people vote in
2020 because we're not going to count on
changing the minds of Trump voters do
enough people vote in 2020 that we can
get this guy out of office I'm not
convinced that we can even though
there's no shortage of reasons to do
that
check out rejected voicemails on the
David Pakman show Instagram feed this is
a new thing where a lot of people say
you know David you air one voicemail a
day we're curious about some of the
voicemails that don't make it onto the
show a producer max is now publishing
rejected voicemails to our Instagram
account at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me on instagram as
well at David Pakman today I want to
tell you about spin King and company
this is an independently owned online
bike shop that has you covered on
everything from frames and wheels to
special accessories and cycling apparel
and everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a 15% discount when you
use the promo code Pakman at checkout
check out their high end tour a carbon
fiber frames check out their
aerospace-grade titanium frames they're
one of the only US distributors of
Pelagos bicycles commuter bike racks
they sell really high-quality
mirror-polished bike tools buy run well
of Japan you can find bicycle stems and
hand
bars by Valachi as well as petal straps
and hip pouches by zulu fixed-gear spin
king and company are the inventors of
the innovative chain genie chain tool
which assists single speed riders in
easily retention
their chain line spin King also
distributes a really unique line of
minimalist yet practical urban backpacks
by brassy of Prague and you can browse
the company's own line of t-shirts
designed and printed by the spin King
and company team I know there are many
people in the David Pakman show audience
that love supporting small business and
buying your next bike parts and cycling
apparel from spin King is a great way to
do it it's a small company they've made
a name for themselves by specializing in
exclusive super quality bike products
that you won't be able to find through
mainstream retailers click the link
under this video use promo code PA KMA
and a check out for a 15% discount off
of your order